Володимире та Віталію, велике спасибі за інтерв'ю
Вітаю в програмі.  Володимире, за кого ви віддали
свій голос в другому турі президентських виборів в Україні?
Все, що відбулося в кабінці, - це моя особиста думка,
-  Ви ходили на вибори?
- Так. Але я не ділитимусь.
- Тим, чи ходили на вибори чи ні?
Ну ви ж чули, мабуть, що, наприклад,
один з кандидатів показав це пресі,
і тут же приїхала поліція.
Зараз поліція точно не приїде,
тому що вибори вже закінчилися.
Добре. Вам можна, бо ви приватна особа.
А от, Віталію, вам уже не можна.
За кого ви віддали свій голос в другому турі президентських виборів?
Найважливіше, незалежно від того, хто буде президентом України,
головне, що хвилює мене, Володимира і мільйони українців,
яким шляхом розвиватиметься далі Україна.
Чи змінить вона свій курс, який обрала,
на євроінтеграцію, демократичні перетворення, реформи?
Це значно важливіше для кожного українця.
У жодному разі не звернути з того шляху,
який обрали п'ять років тому в 2013 році.
І не забуваймо, що дуже багато українців заплатили за цей вибір,
за майбутнє України найціннішим - власним життям
і на Майдані, і захищаючи Україну на Сході.
Віталію, я з вами цілком згодна, але моє питання полягало в іншому.
За кого ви віддали свій голос?
За майбутнє України.
Ви не називатимете прізвища?
Хто для вас уособлює майбутнє України?
Я віддав свій голос за Порошенка і не приховую цього.
Для мене він більш зрозумілий.
Я знаю, чого від цього президента очікувати.
Якщо коротко, чому віддав свій голос,
можу сказати, що Порошенко дуже ефективний президент.
Те, що стосується бюджетної політики.
Об'єднати навколо України міжнародну коаліцію,
об'єднати навколо України тих людей, які підтримують,
і країни, які підтримують, і завдяки їм, фактично,
Україна зберегла свою незалежність.
Що стосується Зеленського.
Людина не представила свою програму.
Ми голосуємо не за персону, а за ті дії, які він представляє,
які він пропонує на майбутнє,
тому що кожен українець бажає знати,
чого йому чекати від майбутнього.
А кожен очікує європейських стандартів життя.
А вас лякає той факт, що президентську посаду,
все ж таки найвищу державну посаду в країні,
я розумію, що Україна - це парламентсько-президентська республіка,
та все ж, обійняла людина з нульовим політичним досвідом?
Можна провести багато-багато-багато паралелей.
Казатиму про те, що знаю.
Коли ти не підготовлений в спорті,
в боксі до якогось поєдинку,
або ти хочеш викладати щось в університеті,
те, що не розумієш чи не знаєш,
ну це й виглядатиме відповідно.
Та історично так склалося,
що, наприклад, в історії Сполучених Штатів
був колишній актор Рональд Рейган.
Але хочу тебе поправити.
- Поправте.
- Перед тим, як стати президентом Сполучених Штатів,
він двічі був сенатором.
- Правильно. Так і мої думки, будь ласка, не випереджайте.
Так і Арнольд Шварценеггер, який прийшов зі спорту,
або, наприклад, дійду до тебе -
колишній боксер став мером міста.
У кожного своя якась певна підготовка.
Що ми маємо нині?
Ми маємо президента - колишнього шоумена.
- А мер-боксер - це добре?
- Ну і я про те ж.
Можна думати стереотипами або вимірювати стереотипами.
Я думаю, що незабаром стане зрозуміло,
в якій ситуації ми опинилися.
А після п'яти років точно буде зрозуміло,
який проміжок часу пройшов
і що було зроблено або не зроблено,
скільки було обіцяно, чи були ці обіцянки виконані чи ні.
Час, так би мовити, найкращий лікар, який усе покаже.
Ви, мабуть, погодитеся зі мною, що тепер
до вашого старшого брата буде менше претензій?
Вітати, засуджувати чи радіти.
Коли я спостерігаю за політиками,
вони радіють, що виграли.
Таке враження, що виграли вони поєдинок чи олімпійську медаль.
Напевно, коли стаєш президентом….
Це питання, чи можна, чи можеш ти себе уявити.
Або як це виглядає.
Це величезний шмат відповідальності.
І радіти цьому як перемозі, я розумію,
я розумію, що передвиборна кампанія і голоси рахуються
і врешті-решт є переможений кандидат і переможець.
Але я також розумію, що особливо
радіти практично немає чому.
А головне, що має бути зроблене,
це та передвиборна кампанія, ті обіцянки,
які були зроблені наперед, їх треба виконати.
Це найскладніше.
Чому ви смієтеся?
Я сміюсь… Коли я виграв вибори мера,
деякі з моїх друзів підходили і казали: "Віталію,
ми не знаємо, вітати тебе чи, може, співчувати?
Тому що це дійсно величезний шмат роботи,
відповідальності і це не привілей.
Віталію, а чому… Я перепрошую, що перебиваю,
а чому, якщо це не привілей, а каторжна праця, усі рвуться до влади?
Не всі у світі, але є певна кількість людей, які хотіли б
обійняти посаду президента, мера Києва і ті,
які потрапили до влади, їх вже доволі важко позбутися.
Відшкребти. Вони приростають до цих крісел.
Так. Чому? Для мене це дилема. Незрозуміло.
Може, поясните?
Певно, у кожного є своя мотивація для цього.
Відшкребти складно. Ви правильно сказали.
У кожного є своя мотивація. Я можу казати про свою мотивацію.
Мотивацію, чому ви хочете залишитися в кріслі мера?
Я за крісло не б'юся, не тримаюсь.
Він у кріслі не сидить,
я його в кріслі жодного разу не бачив.
У мене робочий кабінет - усе місто насправді.
Те, що стосується крісла чи посади, яку обіймаєш,
я відчув, дійсно відчув те, про що ви говорите,
задоволення лише буквально півтора роки тому.
Перші 2,5 роки, коли я приходив додому і піднімався до себе…
у мене таке дзеркало в ліфті є, де я дивився на себе
в дзеркало: здоровезний чоловік, два метри зріст,
м'язи такі, а ледь-ледь тягне ноги.
Потім приходить, дивиться в це дзеркало, піднімаючись нагору уже до
себе в апартаменти, і запитує себе:
"А ти впевнений, що тобі ця чортова робота потрібна?"
Наступного ранку, трохи відпочивши, так само спускаєшся,
вже дивишся: ні, просто так не складу руки.
А почав отримувати задоволення, коли люди
підходять до тебе і ти бачиш:
вони бачать результат твоєї роботи.
Вони дякують тобі за нову дорогу, за новий дім,
дитячий садочок, школу, за новий парк.
І це надає колосальних сил,  ти змінюєш світ навколо себе
і отримуєш від цього велике задоволення.
Чому я буду далі балотуватися? Тому що я поставив собі за  мету
реалізувати декілька ключових проектів для нашого міста.
Це перше. І найважливіше: місто Київ - це приклад
для всіх перетворень у країні.
Ми показуємо. Я дуже радий, що ми запустили
Смарт-сіті в місті Києві, відкритий бюджет.
Ми запустили систему Прозорро.
Поки лише в місті Києві є єдиний парламент, який
голосує персональним голосуванням.
Ми запустили дуже багато процесів, які поширюються по країні.
Чому? Та тому, що я можу жити, і Володя так само,
і в Німеччині, і в Сполучених Штатах, і в будь-якій іншій країні світу.
Але я хочу насолоджуватися такими ж стандартами життя,
які є в Німеччині, у себе вдома в Києві, в Україні.
Я все ж таки хотіла вас перебити. Ми обов'язково поговоримо
про ваші подальші політичні плани,
але я би хотіла повернутися до Володимира Зеленського.
Є одне ключове питання. Мені цікава ваша думка, Віталію:
чому більшість людей, які прийшли 21 квітня на виборчі дільниці,
проголосували за російськомовного єврея?
По-перше, жодного значення в Україні не має національність.
І всі ці розповіді,  що тут українофоби чи українофіли перебувають,
частина українців - фоби, філи і так далі…
В Україні живе понад 70 національностей,
величезна кількість віросповідань, конфесій.
І ніколи не було проблеми, навіть сьогодні можеш
ходити містом Києвом,
спілкуватися німецькою, англійською, російською
і ніхто тобі не відмовить, якщо ти звертаєшся.
Понад половину, а може, половина людей, що живуть у Києві,
говорять російською.
Тобто це вас зовсім не здивувало?
Ні. Знаєте що, я думаю, якби ви питали мою оцінку,
швидше за все, люди голосували не за мову, національність.
Вони втомилися від політиків.
Я їх називаю продавцями повітря.
І показали всім політикам, що ми від вас втомилися.
Ми хочемо проголосувати за людину, яка не має поганого бекграунда,
яка завжди була позитивною, представляла себе позитивно,
грала в кіно, жартувала, дарувала позитивні емоції.
Це, я вважаю, зіграло одну з ключових ролей.
Іще одне важливе питання, це було
однією з тем передвиборних перегонів.
Те, що президент Володимир Зеленський не самостійний,
що за ним стоїть та спонсорує його
один із відомих українських олігархів Ігор Коломойський,
який зараз перебуває в Ізраїлі. Чи так це?
Я не можу ані спростовувати, ані підтверджувати.
Тобто ви не знаєте?
Чому, непрямі, тобто всі про це говорять,
непрямі ознаки того, що канал 1+1 є давнім партнером,
медіапартнером Зеленського.
Це ні для кого не секрет. І усі серіали, усі камеді-клаб,
ні, 95-й Квартал ідуть на цьому каналі.
І пана Зеленського доволі часто помічали
в компанії Ігоря Коломойського, приїздив на день народження,
наскільки телебачення показувало. І це є
непрямими підтвердженнями.
Спростувати або підтверджувати - я у цьому випадку не є тією стороною,
яка може щось стверджувати, це абсолютно відомі публіці факти. Ну і...
На вашу думку, чи буде Ігор Коломойський ляльководом,
а саме так про нього говорять українські політики,
а Володимир Зеленський - маріонеткою?
Так про нього говорив Петро Порошенко.
Дуже не хотілося би, щоб людина на найвищій політичній посаді в Україні
представляла якогось олігарха та відстоювала...
тому що олігарх насправді - це дуже великий бізнесмен,
а цілі та завдання будь-якого бізнесу - це передусім заробляння грошей.
А політик має в першу чергу перед собою ставити інтереси народу,
держави, а не інтереси фінансових відносин та окремих персоналій.
Ось у цьому вся небезпека. І я думаю, що
до цього буде прикута увага всіх  журналістів,
які стежитимуть за діяльністю нового президента.
Але дивіться, Петро Порошенко - про нього говорять
як про олігарха, він один з найбагатших людей країни.
Тим не менше ви вважаєте, що з ним немає
такої проблеми, яка може виникнути із Зеленським?
Так. Так. Так. Насправді ця проблема завжди була в Україні.
І вплив фінансових груп або окремих персоналій
на тих чи інших політиків завжди був топ-темою і темою викриттів,
журналістських розслідувань. І в цьому випадку
українці найбільше побоюються,
що ця історія буде повторюватися
Ви не брали участь звичайно ж у передвиборній кампанії,
але тим не менше ви зробили кілька яскравих заяв,
коли закликали кандидатів у президенти прийти і здати аналізи.
Чи означає це, що ви в якийсь момент
думаєте про участь у політичному житті країни?
Я завжди брав участь.
Я маю на увазі не як громадянин, а як політик.
Ви собі не уявляєте. У мене відбувається Київрада щоразу, коли я сідаю у літак.
Ні, прийом громадян. Прийом громадян
Ну ви ж користуєтеся вашою схожістю.
Постійно. Я намагаюся пояснити, що я не мер.
Але тим не менше: "Ну, ви ж мера знаєте, ну передайте..."
Це зрозуміло, це родинні зв'язки, я говорю зараз серйозно.
Чи плануєте ви брати участь в українській політиці
е як громадянин, не як брат мера Києва, а як самостійна фігура.
Я думав, ви у мене, Жанно, спитаєте, чи планую я повертатися у спорт?
Тому що це напевно цікавіша тема...
Добре, чи плануєте ви повертатися у спорт?
Зараз у медіа якісь суми пропонують за повернення у спорт.
Я відповідаю на це питання "ніколи не говори ніколи"
Ну, це про спорт, а про політику?
Ніколи не говори ніколи.
Станеться це чи ні. У моєму юному віці -
я застряг на рівні двадцяти семи. Мені 43,
але я почуваюся 27-річним.
Прекрасно.
І я розумію, що ніколи не говори ніколи.
Іще величезний відрізок шляху переді мною.
Зачекайте, вибори вже скоро.
І нові виклики. Я дуже радий, що все ж таки створив методику управління викликами,
яку викладаю вже четвертий рік в університеті Санкт-Галлена.
Торік я розпочав у Бостоні, в Гарварді.
Я дуже радий, що ця методика допомагає багатьом людям
і також двом компаніям - німецькому Телекому або компанії SAP.
Я брату заздрю. Вибачте, я переб’ю.
Я пишаюся тим, що маю такого брата.
Ти доповнюєш.
По-перше, чемпіон, чемпіон світу.
Ви знаєте, я дуже колись мріяв вчитися в Гарварді.
Найкращий вуз світу.
Володя нині може вже так говорити:
"Там, де ви мріяли вчитися, я викладав".
А ви підтримаєте брата, якщо він вирішить
брати участь в  українській політиці?
Я підтримаю брата у будь-якому його рішенні,
яке би він не ухвалював.
Це його доля. Це його рішення.
.... було би нерозумно, було би безглуздо
чіплятися до свого брата, говорячи, ні не йди тощо.
Він вирішує, а я при ухваленні будь-якого рішення
підтримував і буду підтримувати брата.
А як ви вважаєте, українське суспільство виграє,
якщо ваш брат прийде в політику?
Я знаю, що за Володимира ніколи нікому не було соромно
і не буде соромно.
Багато хто йде в політику реалізовувати якісь свої амбіції.
На превеликий жаль, сьогодні політик, сам політик,
слово політика дискредитувало себе.
Чому політик - це брехун, обманщик.
Протягом двадцяти восьми років незалежності України
політики змагалися, хто краще розповідає,
хто краще пообіцяє і хто пообіцяє золоті гори.
До речі, ось Володимир Зеленський саме цього не робив.
Він просто мало говорив. Помітили?
Програму свою не представляв. Говорити треба,
але треба не лише говорити, треба і робити.
Я, наприклад, можу одне сказати:
я політиків називаю, великих політиків,
які у нас є, продавці повітря.